what's new this year what's happening
other than finding things in closets
well as you can see in that scene we're
exploring more of the world right we're
going more into the basement of the
school which is equal as terrifying as
you think it is
um and going outside of the school
getting in the Philly understanding
their personal lives and we're really
seeing for the first time these teachers
start a school year and then what that
process is like we picked up mid-school
year last year and this time we wanted
to really take it slow and show people
some of the things that they didn't know
happened before your kids arrive which
is really relevant right now because I
think people really got a good grasp of
what it's like with zoom school you know
all the parents having to yeah because
people are just complaining like oh I
have to do this with my kids I'm like
great the teacher's been doing it for
years with like 30 of them years yeah
you had two I still don't understand
that as a concept because I have I think
on set about 15 to 20 kids in my class
and just trying to get them all quiet to
start rolling that's what I'm saying
yeah yeah it's like herding cats yeah
and then someone has to go to the
bathroom and now we all have to go to
the bathroom but not at the same time
yeah so it's like I'm realizing how much
this job is for a teacher and how much
that of an undertaking that is and to
have kids that aren't your own you know
when people are doing the zoom at least
they're your kids you know what I mean
you know them right but the teachers
take it home yeah yeah I would have been
a teacher had I not done this really for
sure I love it I I wouldn't want to go
in the third grade you know the second
grade the first grade even and people
are like what are you crazy and the same
way I always wanted to have twins and
people who have twins go what are you
crazy that you don't want twins but I I
felt like the more the better you know
so I have five and that's what happened
yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]